to infinity and beyond the wait for
disney's light year is coming to an end
so what do the great artists at disney
do for us they give us the what's what
on one of the greatest pixar characters
of all time while keeping the best
aspects of buzz we're getting an inside
look into his makeover and gadgets old
and new alright strap in for hyper speed
number one we've been promised a pixar
movie unlike any other just ask chris
evans our brand new buzz lightyear i'm a
massive fixer fan i was a kid in a candy
store the artistic team certainly wanted
to make this the most ambitious project
to honor one of the most legendary
animated characters the amount of detail
animators added for this origin story
only strengthened its foundation for
emotional storytelling they also had a
lot of time to make this one as director
angus mclean has had this one brewing
for over 20 years that's right ever
since toy story 2 angus was obsessed
with the idea of a buzz lightyear origin
story
number two reboots of old classics are
no stranger to casting different actors
for the titular roles but with light
year this one's an origin story so why
not bring back tim allen for the voice
of buzz well because they're entirely
different characters so bringing in
chris evans was not only a great idea
but his voice also really emulates
allen's interpretation censors have
detected potential life forms on an
uncharted planet it wouldn't have made
much sense to make tim the voice for the
human form just because he made the toy
version some iconic you kind of just do
a shameless tim allen impression evans
was the first and only choice to lend
his voice to this buzz but stepping into
those shoes was exciting yet
nerve-wracking for the marvel superstar
number three speaking of chris evans did
you know this is his first major
animated film yeah we were a little
surprised too just by the looks of the
trailers it seems like he's just a
natural he does have some experience
voice acting but most of his time was
spent as a hero on set this concept was
a little difficult for evans to get
through separating physical acting and
vocal but he had a great support team
throughout the process he specifically
owes it all to mclean saying so you're
really kind of leaning on the director
and angus is so wonderful you trust that
they know what they're doing and if they
say jump you just say how high and you
just try as many options as possible
number four a new buzz comes with new
characters uzu aduba joins in on the
adventure playing lightyear's first best
friend and confidant alicia hawthorne
from what we can gather from the
trailers we think she may not be in on
this one a whole lot as the plot
thickens but hawthorne's granddaughter
izzy hawthorne played by kiki palmer
takes the role and flies along the
adventure she was so thrilled to join
the team specifically a pixar team i was
so excited to jump in that world as a
fan and as an actor number five with a
great inside scoop on the plot we've
been told that buzz becomes quite the
time traveler the story begins its
second act with him traveling to another
planet little does he know that his time
is moving normally while his friends
back home are aging rapidly by the time
he comes back no the creative team is
not ripping off interstellar they
actually went through some heavy
research to get einstein's theory of
relativity right luckily they got an
interview casually scheduled with an
astronaut at the international space
station no big deal right good thing
they did because it seemed like a lot of
the team had differing opinions on the
matter right so the
faster oh boy
number six the pandemic hit hard for all
of us including the entertainment
industry but this didn't stop the light
year team at pixar they found a way to
get things done and stay on track they
brought their work home with them and
were able to come back when it was safe
to do so
number seven like marvel has its many
outtakes so do cartoons in fact light
year went through a lot of drafts for
multiple scenes they animated dozens of
unseen sequences that unfortunately will
not make it in the final cut some were
pretty necessary to take out and some
were just too hard to let go from the
story creators we've written sequences
that don't exist anymore that are just
so fun number eight sometimes you just
get a little too nervous
and start tap dancing that's exactly the
case for chris evans he excused it as
more of a way to stay occupied in the
booth saying some people whistle or chew
gum and i just kind of find myself
casually soft shoeing it's more of just
a casual thing that sometimes my feet do
without even thinking
number nine original toy story artists
had one thing in mind when designing
buzz lightyear more plastic more toy but
with the launch of the human version
artists become very picky about the
details but why it's about the birth of
a hero not a hero that became a bigger
hero there's so much more to his
appearance than meets the eye so we'll
be nitpicking his features for you as
well
number 10 there are a million different
things to worry about for this character
design but for these animators it had to
be the chin they couldn't just recycle
the old one as it's too big for human
form it took a ton of design mockups to
find the best fit we guess we can say
the original chin was just too beyond
big for anyone to consider human
number 11. we thought there was
something strange about the new buzz
where's the snood you know that purple
cap extension that he wears in toy story
right well for the design of this one
they opted for hair instead we have no
problem with that but it's just such a
staple to the iconic look goodbye great
snood we'll miss ya
number 12 who knew a hand could tell a
thousand stories the overall hand
animations really mattered during each
scene for the animators
well really the director director angus
really harps on the idea that even the
way a character presses a button tells a
lot about their overall personality they
took great care in how buzz holds his
weapons and operates machines pressing
them lightly or aggressively to propel
his emotional journey we never thought
we'd ever have an entry like this we
just really have to hand it to them for
the attention to detail
number 13. as every big budget kids
movie sells tickets they also make a lot
in merchandise and while the toy story
franchise was never a stranger to great
memorabilia lightyear intends to up the
ante a little with some of the original
gadgets like the signature wrist tech
and laser beam we get interesting new
ones as well but the gadget design isn't
what's most impressive it's all in the
belt animators spent a long time making
buzz's belt as realistic as possible
down to the ribbing in the belt buckle
all we have to say is
just shut up and take our money
number 14. what a crafty guy mclean is
his fascination with creativity knows no
bounds whenever he has an idea for
something in animation he just makes it
out of legos and with the advanced 3d
modeling software
he's able to send it to an artist and
get it rendered to a digital model one
would think working at pixar is a dream
come true but getting to play with legos
at an adult job awesome
number 15. a spin-off movie is nothing
without a few throwbacks to the original
and along with the many included in
light year we got one so subtle not a
lot of fans would really catch it that
orange suit we see buzzwearing on his
adventure is actually an ode to one of
his very first concept designs lunar
larry we're kind of glad lunar larry
didn't make it past the page lunar larry
to the rescue doesn't really give us a
whole lot of comfort but this one's
really an awesome little easter egg to
honor the great minds of toy story we
can feel safe in our minds that tim
allen's character is not being ripped
off or copied in the new film and since
director angus maclean has been there
since the very beginning we think we can
trust that buzz is in good hands so
who's coming with us to buy all the new
light year gear we won't tell we promise